[Musik]
nach zusammen herzlich willkommen zu zdf
heute live und ihrem live stream zu
aktuellen diskussionen und themen und
das heute die zahl die traurige rekord
zahl des tages oder besser fast dieses
jahres 590 denn so viele menschen sind
innerhalb von 24 stunden an oder mit dem
corona virus gestorben das sind so viele
wie noch nie in deutschland dieses jahr
und überhaupt seit beginn dieser
pandemie und auch die zahl der kobert
patienten auf intensivstationen ist auf
einem neuen rekordniveau angekommen
aktuell sind 4278 menschen in
intensivmedizinischer behandlung
aufgrund des corona virus mehr als die
hälfte nämlich 59 prozent von ihnen
werden beatmet und das bringt die
krankenhäuser in manchen regionen an den
rand ihrer auslastung kliniken am limit
haben wir deswegen diesen stream genannt
und wollen die frage stellen wie viel
die krankenhäuser eigentlich noch
leisten können das möchten wird leicht
besprechen mit professor uwe janssens
präsident der die wie der deutschen
interdisziplinären vereinigung für
intensiv und notfallmedizin außerdem ist
er chefarzt der klinik für innere
medizin mit internistische
intensivmedizin am st antonius hospital
in eschweiler
hallo herr professor jahns ja ich grüße
sie guten abend gleich mal die
wichtigste frage vorab ist die lage wie
wir sie jetzt haben in den
krankenhäusern in deutschland noch
beherrschbar und wenn ja wie lange noch
ja sie ist noch beherrschbar
das kann man im augenblick sagen aber in
einigen regionen das haben sie in der
anmoderation schon gesagt stehen wir
schon am limit nicht aber mit dem rücken
fast zur wand weil die belastungen durch
diese hohen infektionszahlen anhaltend
hoch sind wie lange noch wenn das so
weiter gehen mit täglich 20 bis 22
jahren infektions neuen infektionen
zahlen werden nicht nur die zahl der
todesfälle weiter so hoch bleiben
sondern auch die zahl der intensiv
medizinisch zu behandeln und co mit 19
prozent und genau das ist was uns
irgendwann mal in die knie zwingt
erstens zweitens das personal ist jetzt
schon in einigen regionen einen hot
spots regionen metropolregionen
am rande ihrer belastungsfähigkeit
angelangt das darf man gar nicht aus dem
auge verlassen
wir sind jetzt seit monaten in einem
dauermodus und gerade letzten zwei
monate waren sehr anstrengend auch das
kann problematisch werden das wollen wir
heute mal intensiver besprechen wir
können uns aber erstmal eine grafik
angucken die wir auf unserer seite heute
de vorbereitet haben die schalten wir
jetzt mal auch mit monitor neben mir und
da kann man sehen so viel intensivbetten
sind aktuell belegt und das ist jetzt
vielleicht ein bisschen irre führen dass
man alles sie sind denn grau ist
unkritisch das stimmt nicht weil auch
dort kann man jetzt mal sehen zum
beispiel ein dunkelgraues gebiet hier in
der mitte des landes sagen weil den
kreis goslar also goslar kreis
niedersachsen dort sind 82 prozent der
betten schon belegt mit 31 prozent 31
patienten dass darunter nur einer mit 19
das geht jetzt aber wenn wir ein
kreisweiter gucken hier sömmerda in
thüringen 100 prozent der betten sind
belegt mit sechs patienten einer mit 19
ein kreisweiter sechs patienten im
saale-holzland-kreis 100 prozent der
betten belegt da gibt es keinen koop 19
patienten das ist in holzminden
ebenfalls der fall 100 prozent der
betten belegt 14 patienten haben sie da
und keiner micro wird 19 aber das heißt
jetzt nicht unbedingt dass die lage
entspannt ist wenn wir schon quasi nur
so anhand der normalen erkrankungen ans
limit in man auf manchen
intensivstationen kommen was passiert
denn dann wenn jetzt jemand daran kommt
der beatmet werden muss ja ein suchender
schöne nicht vergessen
wir reden dauernd natürlich nur über
krupp 19 die meisten patienten haben
halt krank und 19
und genau diese große anzahl an
patienten ist ja auch weiter gut zu
versorgen
wir haben halt schwer erkrankter guter
gerade cupid patient aber wir haben den
meisten patienten sind halt nicht so mit
patienten und die gehören auch
verseuchten genau dafür müssen wir ein
puffer haben
denn das in notfällen die tagtäglich
hereinkommen herzinfarkte akute
entzündungen im bauch im bereich akute
gefäßverschlüsse das sind alles schwere
krankheitsbilder die wir auch versorgen
müssen und die zusätzlichen kita kranken
patienten in berlin beispielsweise über
25 prozent anteil das ist sehr viel
die kommen ja addon die kommen
zusätzlich deshalb geraten
in einigen regionen diese
intensivstation die normalerweise immer
23 betten 43 betten frei haben muss um
die notfälle zu versorgen an den rand
ihrer belastungsfähigkeit das heißt wenn
wir jetzt noch die zahlen gucken in
normalen jahren hatten wir auch schon
einen kommentar in die richtung vor der
sendung in normalen jahren ist das
system auch schon am limit teilweise
sehe ich das richtig
ja ein punkt den werden wir mit
sicherheit noch besprechen ist ja der
chronische pflege personalmangel der
fach personalmangel und der besteht seit
jahren also wir haben deutschland
weltmeister haft viele betten
intensivbetten aufgestellt das muss man
an der stelle auch noch mal betonen
vergleich war das mal mit unseren
nachbarländern sind wir wirklich ganz an
der spitze also wirklich an der spitze
weltweit knapp 34 betten auf 100000
einwohner
ich gebe mal eine vergleichszahl in den
niederlanden direkt bei mir um die ecke
6,6 werden noch 100000 aber da sind
jetzt online bringt ja nix ne nein das
ist genau der punkt wir können dann auch
noch 100 betten auf 100000 einwohner
haben wenn dir nicht das personal habe
und da ist eines der kern
schwierigkeiten
wir haben den nämlich nicht weltmeister
im personal da stehen wir in europa ganz
weit hinten in bezug auf die anzahl der
betten haben wir viel zu viel viel zu
wenig pflegepersonal und das fällt uns
jetzt in dieser kritischen phase auf die
füße in 1 müssen sie wissen die quint 19
patienten auf den intensivstationen die
haben wir eine viel höhere und
betreuungsaufwand die sind ja in der
betreuung so aufwendig dass jetzt zum
teil eins zu eins gepflegt sein müssen
also sind nicht vergleichbar mit ich
sage meinen anzustreben einem normalen
intensiv stadt patient wo eine schwester
ein pfleger bei zwei patienten drei
patient vielleicht versorgt haben sein
die benötigen einen sehr hohen aufwand
personaler fand binden vier personen
und das macht es jetzt im moment
tatsächlich zusätzlich zu allen anderen
aufgaben die wir in den herbstmonaten ja
immer haben schwierig zum teil sehr
schwierig darüber sprechen wir gleich im
detail noch mal aber vorher möchten wir
einmal einen blick werfen in eine klinik
wie es dort aussieht gerade jetzt in der
herbstzeit de schon schwierig ist und
dann kommt noch dazu kaum haben wir die
kamera angemacht kommt bereits wieder
ein neuer patient auf die
intensivstation im klinikum
niederlausitz der leitende oberarzt
thomas schneider nimmt sich seiner an
routiniert und professionell denn die
patienten sollen nicht spüren dass hier
eigentlich ausnahmezustand herrscht
klinik ärzte und pfleger sind am limit
etwas nie dagewesen ist manchmal das
wahnsinnig weil die situation selbst die
erfahrensten kollegen bei uns vollkommen
übermannt und vor aufgaben stellt die
wir so noch nicht erlebt haben
50 corona patienten werden derzeit
insgesamt in der klinik behandelt und
sie können trotz hightech medizin nicht
jeden retten die begleitung der
sterbenden auf der isolierstation für
die pflegerinnen und pfleger neben der
angst vor ansteckung die größte
belastung quasi allein da sind wir als
fremde die den patienten in den letzten
atemzügen begleiten und nicht die
geliebten angehörigen das ist das was
uns auch ziemlich dans la niña agiert
weil die versorgung wegen überlastung
und personalmangel sei akut gefährdet
ist unternimmt die klinik nun einen
ungewöhnlichen schritt und bittet sogar
freiwillige in der bevölkerung um hilfe
in jedem bereich zudem werden seit
vergangener woche fast täglich patienten
verlegte haben gestern sieben patienten
heraus verlegt wir werden heute fünf
patienten raus verlegen und ich kann
ihnen sagen diese plätze sind bis morgen
alle wieder gefüllt dieser helikopter
bringt eine corona intensiv patientin
ins 150 kilometer entfernte berlin
es wird an diesem tag nicht der letzte
flug bleiben
tja so angespannte lage in dieser klinik
was es mit den kliniken macht diese
pandemie das besprechen wir heute mit
professor uwe janssens der präsident der
die wie der deutschen interdisziplinären
vereinigung für intensiv und
notfallmedizin chefarzt außerdem in
eschweiler an einer klinik uns mit euch
und ihnen natürlich fragen und
kommentare sehr gerne in die dafür
vorgesehenen spalten oder auch per e
mail an zdf heute.de zdf.de dann werden
wir gucken was wir damit rein nehmen
können und ich habe hier schon jede
menge fragen einer möchte ich aber
vorher noch stellen weil das gerade
gesehen haben herr professor jahns
da flog ein hubschrauber mit einer
patientin quasi eine stadt weiter dass
der patient die patientin wurde verlegt
ist das etwas was jetzt tatsächlich
wovor ich ja mehr sorgen machen muss
dass wir nicht in ein krankenhaus
anklopfe dass mir gesagt wird
entschuldigung geht hier nicht mehr
bitte fahren sie weiter oder wir
verlegen sie so schnell wie möglich ich
würde es mal positiv ausdrücken ist ja
schön dass wir das in der organisation
realisieren können dass tatsächlich
patientin die dann nicht mehr adäquat
oder nicht mehr ausreichend versorgt
dann können weil sie noch zusatz
therapien benötigen überbrachte zentrum
fertig werden das geht jetzt noch um
scheint ja doch zu funktionieren und ist
auch notwendig nein ich glaube sie
müssen warum wir keine angst haben dass
nicht versorgt werden sie müssen aber
befürchten einen regionen das war ja
grad eine region wo eine starke
belastung ist dass diese krankenhäuser
das nicht mehr nutzen können um das mal
so auszudrücken sondern dass sie dann
auf die hilfe anderer kliniken
zurückgreifen müssen das ist genau
vorgesehen in den nationalen konzept in
sogenannt kleeblatt konzept nur
deutschland fünf regionen aufgeteilt
haben wo dann die patienten in
kooperierende übergeordnete zentrum
verlegt werden
da sehen wir übrigens in tenby wie
intensiv ist ja was eben aufgerufen
namen da können die kliniken wenn sie im
mentalen bereich sind sehr genau sehen
in welchem umkreis bei ihnen wetten noch
zur verfügung sind und können dann
direkt auch telefonische kontakt
aufnehmen und eine eventuell anstehende
verlegung dann organisieren
ich hatte so ein paar fragen und
kommentare zur auslastung der
krankenhäuser zb von regina pinsel auf
facebook kann es sein dass die kliniken
an der belastungsgrenze sind weil über
600 kliniken schon geschlossen wurden
in den letzten jahren ja dass ist eine
diskussion die wird ja sagt sagen
geführt und ich kann ihnen sagen lieber
herr fritzl genau die diskussion wird
derzeit weiter geführt trotz corona das
tatsächlich in deutschland immer wieder
die diskussion aufgaben wir hätten zu
viele kliniken in diesem jahr muss man
sagen hat sich das ein bisschen
umgedreht denn eigentlich sind jetzt
alle ganz froh inklusive unseres
bundesgesundheitsministers dass wir
eigentlich genügend kriegen hat um das
abzufangen was woanders übrigens in
anderen ländern europa nicht der fall
war denken sie an die bilder in italien
wo wir tatsächlich auf 100000 einfach
nur zehn intensivbetten haben je 8,6
intensivbetten haben sie sehen diese
dramatische unterschiedliche zahl acht
er viermal soviel intensivbetten in
deutschland tatsächlich muss diese
diskussion und wird die in den nächsten
jahren weitergeführt haben wir zu viele
kliniken welche klingen sollen
geschlossen wenn und welche kliniken und
welche betten sind für die
daseinsvorsorge dar und wir müssen in
einen neuen dialog einsteigen was
gesundheit für uns bedeutet und wie die
krankenhäuser aufgestellt sein sollen
und wie sie vor allem finanziert werden
sollen das ist ein extrem schwieriger
komplexe schwere diskussion gute frage
klare antwort kann ich nicht geben im
moment wird man meinen
besser keine klinik zu machen aber sie
werden sehen es würden da prozesse
angestoßen werden da wird eine
umstrukturieren stattfinden die
wahrscheinlich in teilen auch ganz
sinnvoll ist damals ja auch genau das
wollte ich gerade sein da gibt es ja
auch stimmen die sagen also viele kleine
krankenhäuser die keine spezialisierung
haben bringen in der fläche nichts außer
das gute gefühl ich habe ein krankenhaus
irgendwie in der nähe aber verteilung
auf größere zentren wäre da sinnvoll da
gibt es ja auch entsprechende studien zu
wir werden die krankenhäuser in
deutschland in bestimmte stufen
einteilen insgesamt drei stufen das
haben wir notfallversorgung jetzt auch
schon in der umsetzung befindet sich das
dann wird man schauen wie in regionen wo
sie sehr ländliche regionen haben was
benötigen wir da an versorgung für die
bevölkerung dass sicher gestellt dass
sie immer auch ein chirurgen haben der
meine wunde nähen kann der blinddarm
operiert kann und was werden wir auch in
übergeordneten zentren vielleicht dann
versorgen müssen die etwas
spezialisierter sind ich habe die
diskussion darf und muss man führen denn
wir haben einen sehr
teures gesundheitsthemen auf der anderen
seite wollen wir und das ist unser ganz
fest erklärte wille die versorgung der
bevölkerung auch sicherstellen übrigens
auch in gebieten die vielleicht
schwächer besiedelt sind in anderen
ländern leistet man sich dann den luxus
und sagt an und sagt die bevölkerung gut
ich bin bereit
die skandinavischen länder
beispielsweise 100 200 kilometer zu
fahren und dann eine optimale hoch
spezialisierte versorgung zu bekommen
das ist ein prozess der bus in gang
gesetzt werden dann müssen wir mit der
gesellschaft aber diskutieren bis jetzt
ist das leider gottes in deutschland
nicht geschehen gut vielleicht ist ja
die pandemie tatsächlich ein anlass dass
wir darüber reden kommen wir tatsächlich
mal von diesen großen meter thema zu der
ganz praktischen problematik die wir
gerade haben denn wir haben es ja schon
gesagt betten sind da aber die freien
betten sind ja nicht immer auch
unbedingt tatsächlich mit pflegekräften
versorgt da gibt's patientenschützer die
haben den kliniken vorgeworfen das zwar
freie intensivbetten gemeldet wurden da
gab es ja auch prämien in den ersten lok
dauerwelle die aber gar nicht genutzt
werden können weil gar nicht genug
personal da ist können sie als die wii
als quasi die institutionen die
versuchen alles zu bündeln von den
zahlen her überhaupt kontrollieren ob
das stimmt was ihre krankenhäuser dort
melden
sehr gute frage wir haben in der
anfangsphase das muss man sagen ist ein
einmaliges projekt gewählt weil gibt es
das überhaupt nicht viele
schwierigkeiten gab dazu einem
geordneten meldeverfahren zu kommen wir
sind als fachgesellschaft ja nicht die
polizei bekam keine kontrollmechanismen
wir haben im verlauf der letzten wochen
und monate diverse mitteilungen
herausgeschickt an die meldungen
krankenhäuser und sie aufgefordert
korrekt zu melden
das geschieht mittlerweile muss man
sagen wir relativ genau und wenn wir
jetzt auf die zahl der freien betten
schauen
die sind nach unseren aufforderung nur
die korrekt betreibt barren betten zu
werden tatsächlich haben die abgenommen
und zwar substanzielle abgenommen wir
gehen davon aus dass die jetzt richtig
melden wir haben das übrigens mit
anderen meldesystem in nrw vor kurzem
abgelegten das ist ein event das notfall
meldesystem was bettenkapazität meldet
da stimmt die zahl der gemeldeten
tatsächlich exakt überein
machen sie das mal und vielleicht auch
mal dass die vorbeigehen und mal nach
stimmt wir können das im ganztag
gesellschaft wir haben ich sage ganz
ehrlich wir haben dem
bundesgesundheitsminister vorgeschlagen
das wäre doch mal eine gute idee den
medizinischen dienstes der medizinische
dienst der krankenkassen waren die
kritiken zu schicken um alles zu
überprüfen was ist da betreibt dann
nicht und betreiber dieser vorschlag ist
nicht aufgegriffen worden
ich hätte den ganz richtig gefunden in
der tat da gebe ich ihnen ganz klar
recht das ist ja mittlerweile in der
presse im fernsehen überall gut
dargestellt waren es gab kliniken
die haben dann betten aufgestellt die
haben sie sich übrigens auch finanzieren
lassen da gab es ja geld dafür
die sind aber vom ersten moment an nicht
betreiber und das ist natürlich nicht so
schön da würde ich eher kritisch als
anmerken als bürger das würde ich nicht
so gerne sehen da sind gelder geflossen
und da hätte ich doch erwartet dass den
klinikclowns dann müssen sie das
personal dafür bereitstellen ein bett
ein monitor nützt nichts wir brauchen
die menschen die dahinter stehen
um die patienten zu versorgen jetzt geht
es ja die große diskussion ob wir einen
harten lockdown brauchen also quasi
wirklich ein komplettes runter ein
runterfahren des landes oder ob die
maßnahmen ausgerechnet habe ausgereicht
haben wenn wir mal auf die quasi
hochrechnungen gucken das haben wir
gestern hier schon gemacht haben wir mal
mit einem kuhfuß simulator geschaut wie
das aussieht dann ist dabei
herausgekommen wenn wir jetzt weiter bei
diesem wert 1 bleiben den wir ja
ungefähr gerade haben dann bleibt ja
auch ungefähr die zahl der infizierten
gleich ist bleibt die ungefähr die zahl
der menschen gleicht die wahrscheinlich
auf die intensivstation kommen wenn man
davon ausgehen dass ich das alles so
gleich weiter verteilt dann kann man
doch sagen sie sagen gerade die
krankenhäuser kommen damit einigermaßen
hin wo liegt das problem dann
tatsächlich kann man dann nicht einfach
tatsächlich weitermachen wie bisher
ja wenn sie aber jetzt mal ganz genau an
das ist definitiv die letzten tage und
wochen verfolgen hat sehen sie dass wir
tatsächlich einen täglich im augenblick
täglich zwar leichten aber weiterhin
stetigen anstieg der zunahme an coop 19
patienten sehen sagen wir mal wir hätten
jetzt sieben tage am stück 20.000
infizierte neuinfektionen
das wären in der woche 140000 so und wir
gehen im augenblick davon aus dass circa
ein bis vielleicht ungünstiger weise
zwei prozent dieser infizierten personen
irgendwann mal und zwar zehn bis 14 tage
später auf einer intensivstation
ankommen das wären dann bei 140.000
fälle pro woche in einer neuinfektionen
irgendwann mal zweieinhalb wochen später
1400 ungünstigen fall 2800 und
erstaunlicherweise ist diese zahl im
moment nicht so dramatisch ansteigen
denn das würden wir irgendwann nicht
mehr schaffen denn sie müssen ja wissen
die patienten kommen ja nicht hin die
liegen ja werden sie einmal auf die
intensivstation kommen 10 14 bad wird
sogar 24 30 tage das heißt die liegen da
belegen ein wetten dass belegen sie
dauerhaft und sagen sie jeden tag einen
patienten dieser art eine patientin die
so lange auf der intensivstation dazu
agieren dann ist das system irgendwann
mal zu
das muss jedem vollkommen klar sein ich
kann ihnen sagen wir haben ungünstige
prognose modelle die wir im augenblick
noch zusammenfassung jetzt morgen
übermorgen noch mal veröffentlicht
werden wenn wir so weitermachen wie
bisher werden wir halt nicht in einem
steak state weiter segeln sondern wir
werden in eine überbelastung situation
reinkommen das dann aber spätestens
mitte januar als ergebnis einer
lockerungen um das weihnachtsfest herum
und das betrachten wir mit absoluter
sorge und erweisen wir gemeinsam über
uns mit der leopoldina seit tagen sehr
klar darauf hin es heißt dann ja quasi
dass krankenhäuser aus dem betrieb
ausscheiden müssten das ist ja quasi
diese fachterminus dafür das heißt also
man fährt alles runter was nicht der
ringen gebraucht wird und versuchte
quasi in einen notbetrieb zu schalten
in manchen krankenhäusern ist das schon
geschehen zum beispiel im bayerischen
zwiesel nahe der tschechischen grenze
und da haben wir mal den chefarzt dort
gefragt dr christian poetzel wie es
eigentlich dazu gekommen ist
es ist so dass inzwischen über drei tage
hinweg die extrem viele positive viele
patienten hatten vier haben vier
stationären patienten auf 34 so dass wir
das nicht mehr welt empfunden und hast
diesen berichten unsere kollegen von den
musste weil wir irgendwann aufgrund des
karstadt ist bei credit personal das
nicht mehr bewältigen können
bei der ersten welle haben wir im
maximum 13 stationen zu versorgen wir
waren in der lage die patienten in einer
klinik nämlich ein pächter zu
konzentrieren mit ein zwei ausnahmen
jetzt abonnieren von einer wirklich fast
sorgen monsterwelle überrascht die uns
in beiden kliniken geht es zum heutigen
tag stand 67 stationären patienten es
ist ein base aufkommen was keine ideen
kein volk die wir im moment will ich
gerade noch so schlimme ist ja und da
schließt sich direkt eine frage an von
dann jeder caro auf facebook warum
binden die kogit patienten so viel
personal die frage gebe ich weiter an
professor die jansens was ist quasi da
das problem sag ich mal ja gute sehr
gute frage
das versuche ich mal so schnell wie
möglich zu beantworten kopitz 19
patienten sind passieren wird mehr wenn
die ins krankenhaus kommen
ein problem in ihrer lunge haben des
virus befällt ja zunächst mal die lunge
kann aber auch andere organe betreffen
diese patienten kommen mit einer
sauerstoffunterversorgung haben luftnot
atemnot und haben auch viele ängste
sorgen und sie noch sehr aufgeregt haben
diese patienten müssen isoliert werden
die können mit anderen cupid patienten
zusammengelegt werden
aber das gelingt nicht immer so dass die
patienten dann in ein zimmer in denen
wir das ganze zimmer blockiert ist diese
patienten müssen wenn sie noch nicht auf
intensivstationen versorgt mit einer
hoch sicherheitsausrüstung verseucht
das heißt die krankenschwester der
krankenpfleger der arzt muss sich
komplett einmal anziehen mit einem
schutzkittel mit einer mit einer
schutzbrille mit einem fb2 maske fiel
mir auf dass man da fertig ist dauert
das für aufrüstung der aufrüstung da
sind sie schon mal fünf sechs bis zehn
minuten beschäftigt fünf wenn sie
schnell sind sie müssen das sorgfältig
anziehen und sie müssen dann wenn sie
dem zimmer sind und wenn sie den
patientinnen dem patient versorgt haben
sich nachher wieder entkleiden diese
entscheidung ist auch ein sehr
aufwendiger prozess weil sie immer
darauf achten müssen dass sie die
kontaminiert liefert die verunreinigt
ez dass die wii so entsorgen und sich
dauernd immer wieder desinfizieren dass
sie sich dann nicht selber aus versehen
mit eventuell virus behaftet und
material an die finger geraten und dann
nachher sich selber da infizieren das
heißt das ist ein sehr aufwendiger
vorgang ist der gründung um die
pflegekräfte häufig auch mal ein zwei
stunden bei den patienten dann drin
bleiben weil das immer an und ausziehen
sich gar nicht lohnt das ist sehr
wichtig so das haben sie richtig da kann
genau das ist der fall aber wir sind ja
jetzt noch auf der normalstation auf der
normalstation dauert die versorgung dann
auch etwas länger das sind patienten die
auch große ängste haben die sind
psychisch neben der physischen
körperlichen erkrankung sehr belastet
und brauchen einen hohen grad an
zuwendung sie sind isoliert das haben
wir eben in dem beitrag gehört
abgetrennt von ihnen angehören das ist
eine enorme belastung und das
pflegepersonal wie krankenschwester
erfasst der die tränenden augen standen
geber berichtete die brauchen einen
hohen grad der zuwendung das erfordert
viel einfühlungsvermögen viel eigene
widerstandsfähigkeit auch psychische
widerstandsfähigkeit der pflegekräfte
und auf der intensivstation
da sind die patient noch kränker und
dann sind sie in der ersten phase wenn
sie nicht bearbeitet werden werden sie
mit nicht invasiven verfahren nämlich
mit einem hoch schluss sauerstoff mit
nasen brillen mit masken brave das
erfordert einen enormen zuspruch eine
enorme unterstützung durch die
pflegekräfte die dann immenses leisten
müssen am wetter des patient und dann
auch gar nicht aus dem zimmer gehen
können richtig die sind ein zwei stunden
begleiten diese patienten auch zu
verhindern dass es zu einer
beratungspflicht lichkeit kommt um sie
zu unterstützen zu motivieren und ihnen
hilfe zu bieten
das ist sehr anstrengend wenn eine
pflegekraft wenn sie sehen nach 12
stunden aus dem zimmer kommen ist das
gesicht verquollen wenn sie die maske ab
denn sie sind völlig durchgeschwitzt
weil die kittel auch feuchtigkeit nach
außen nicht abgeben das ist eine
körperlich aber auch psychisch
belastende tätigkeit und nicht mit dem
vergleich mit der versorgung von normal
kranken und das mal zu sagen oder
anderen kritisch kranken patienten
wollte mal fragen ich war auch schon im
krankenhaus da kam dann vielleicht
dreimal am tag jemand rein hat gefragt
ob es mir gut geht und dann
wie ich gesagt ja tut ein bisschen weh
oder ich hab mal geklingelt eine halbe
stunde gedauert bis jemand kommt das ist
bei coop patienten anders zuerst quasi
fast die ganze zeit jemand an der seite
ja weil weil der zustand sehr schnell
ändern kann oder was ist der grund dafür
richtig wir haben sich die passieren auf
normalstation die können sie nicht
einfach ein zimmer touren sagen wir
kommen meinen 2 34 stunden mit einer
denn diese patienten ins krankenhaus
kommen haben eine hohes risiko relativ
schnell mit der beatmung schlechter zu
werden das heißt wir müssen eng matschig
in den räumen nach schauen uns um die
patienten kümmern atemfrequenz erfassen
diese sauerstoffsättigung erfassen die
uns auskunft darüber gibt ob die lunge
nur ausreichend arbeit temperatur messen
kreislauf parameter hin dass wir nicht
verpassen den moment wo ein patient von
der normalstation dann eventuell auf
eine intensivstation verlegt muss das
ist ein sehr aufwendiger und
personalintensiver prozess nicht nur auf
der intensivstation nämlich auch auf den
normalen stationen dazu passende frage
die schließt sich gleich an auf youtube
von voice and kite wie schnell könnte
man den menschen ausbilden um kuwait
patienten betreuen zu können wenn ich
sie jetzt mal kurz zusammenfassen habe
ich das gefühl also innerhalb dieser
pandemie schaffen wir das nicht mehr
oder
nein es gibt schulungsprogramm und wir
haben auch eine leitung der zu verfassen
nach kurzer zeit die ein
schulungsprogramm was an der
universitätsklinik aachen entwickelt
worden ist
für ganz deutschland als vorschlag
bietet sie können in der tat
verschiedene kategorien an helfenden im
gesundheitswesen also zum beispiel
medizinstudenten krankenschwester
krankenpfleger die in anderen bereichen
mittlerweile eingesetzt sind ausbilden
und für spezielle module ausbilden sie
können aber nicht diese helfenden dazu
aus den komplett eine kurve 19 patienten
auf der intensivstation zu versorgen das
kann allenfalls nur unterstützende
tätigkeiten seien verantwortliche
tätigkeiten im zusammenhang mit einem
schwer krank und 19 patienten können und
werden nicht ausgebildet weil das
juristisch gar nicht machbar wäre aber
in der tat können wir und das hat das
beispiel aus der klinik gezeigte leute
anwerben die eine unterstützung
darstellen
die die pflegekräfte vor ort entlasten
können indem sie ihnen tätigkeiten
abnehmen die jetzt nicht es steht ja in
der coop 19 versorgung notwendig sind
sondern die im allgemeinen stationslauf
gut zu erledigen sind da kann man
tatsächlich hilfskräfte studenten
auszubildende in den gesundheits und
pflegeberufen und schon gelernte
krankenpflegerin krankenpfleger
hinzuziehen die uns dann unterstützen
soll ich schaue mal kurz in die
kommentare hier gibt es ein paar
anmerkungen die möchte ich der mann
zeigen hier auf youtube zum beispiel
schreibt alia mal ein guter freund
arbeitet als krankenpfleger im klinikum
vivantes kreuzberg aktuell werden über
60 patienten versorgt zu normalen zeiten
gibt es unter 10 also nein kurve das
keiner verschwörung das passt ganz gut
dazu dass auf facebook gerade solche
etwas merkwürdigen und ich glaube durch
weg unwahren erklärungsmuster verbreitet
werden was wirklich hinter cupid stecken
würde wirklich in anführungszeichen
liebe kommentatoren das könnt ihr euch
sparen wir werden diese unwahrheiten
sowieso so schnell wie möglich wieder
löschen weil das einfach fakten frei ist
zeigt ist so ich habe eine frage die
finde ich aber ganz gut hier auf youtube
ist es ja durchaus gemischt kann man
nicht schon immun pflegekräfte ohne den
hohen schutz augenblick markiert noch
mal hier ist es uwe engelmann markieren
muss ja mal ein kurs drin machen ja uwe
engelmann kann man nicht schon immun der
pflegekräfte ohne den hohen schutz
ancona patienten arbeiten lassen also
sprich wenn die pflegekraft das pech
hatte herr professor jahns schon lang
wird er krank zu sein oder tatsächlich
jetzt schnell eine impfung zu kriegen
kann man dann sage ich dass die ganze
zeitung sein der kann nichts mehr
passieren
gute frage klare antwort wir wissen noch
viel zu wenig darüber wir wissen nicht
genau ob eine person die schon einmal an
gruppe 19
er ist auf ewig und drei tage immun ist
wir wissen und das gibt schon
publizierte fällt das personen nochmals
innerhalb kurzer zeit an kuwait 19
also da muss ich leider gottes in dem
fall auflegen
ich würde sagen es wäre unverantwortlich
wenn wir leute sagen nur weil sie schon
mal corona gehabt hätten
1908 gewesen die schicken wir jetzt ohne
schutz kleinen rein
am anfang hat uns das wirklich enorm
beschäftige märz april daten nämlich gar
nichts und da war immer gesagt das
können wir nicht verantworten und ich
würde auch jetzt nicht verantworten eine
pflegekraft auch wenn ich weiß dass die
krone hatte in dieser situation zu
schicken wir benötigen das ist auch
mittlerweile gottseidank flächen denkt
relativ gut umgesetzt diese persönliche
schutzausrüstung da geht kein weg daran
vorbei und das würde ich keine
pflegekraft egal ob sie schon mal
infiziert horny ziehen wir zumuten das
können wir nicht verantworten dass diese
verantwortung würde ich auch nicht
übernehmen
so jetzt haben wir wieder über probleme
und schwierigkeiten gesprochen aber es
gibt ja nicht nur schlechte nachrichten
sondern es gibt ja durchaus auch sehr
viele positive nachrichten menschen
verlassen die intensivstation geheilt
und können wieder in ihr leben zurück
und wir haben dann mal michael kloss
interviewt er ist ehrenamtlicher corona
begleiter so nennt sich das also jemand
der quasi auf der station mit hilft auch
vor allem emotional unterstützt die
angehörigen in stuttgart ist der tätig
und haben ihnen danach seinen
emotionalsten momenten gefragt also der
emotionalste moment ist tatsächlich
gewesen und das ist noch gar nicht so
lange her als ich erlebt habe wie eine
patientin und die wir uns sehr große
sorgen gemacht haben dann doch einen
guten verlauf bekommen hat und jetzt
zwischenzeitlich sogar ansprechbar ist
und mit ihrer familie telefonieren kann
sich ausdrücken kann zwar etwas
schwierig aber es funktioniert und das
war ein emotional ganz starke moment als
ich dann erlebt habe wie die patienten
darauf reagiert hat und wie die
angehörigen dann entsprechend am telefon
sich verhalten haben ja freudentränen
jubelschreie und ein ganz großes
gar nicht eine ganz große freude darüber
kam das sind mit tatsächlich auch die
tränen gelaufen dabei herr professor
jahns präsident der die wie haben sie
auf solche geschichten dass sie uns ein
bisschen mut machen können ja ich finde
diesen kommunikativen aspekt unglaublich
wichtig in der ersten phase märz april
hatten wir alle so eine angst dass sich
jemand an steckt und so weiter und ich
finde diese api soli rung dieser
menschen ab isolierung von den angaben
ist eigentlich so mit das schlimmste an
der ganzen sache und die
krankenschwester die eben berichtet
hatte dass die patienten alleine
verstärken
ich würde mir dringend wünscht und das
propagieren wir auch wollen sie in
unserer fachgesellschaft und versuchen
das auch umzusetzen dass wir alles alle
hebel in bewegung setzen dass menschen
mit solchen erkrankungen nicht alleine
sind wir können es doch sicherstellen
wenn wir angehörige entsprechend
ausstatten dass sie auch tatsächlich zu
ihren erkrankten personen kommen das
gilt ja auch für die altenheime also
diese ganzen furchtbaren geschichten
dass alte menschen in altenheimen
erkranken dann weiß ich es auch nicht
mehr wollen aufnehmen denn die station
nicht verbracht werden und ins
krankenhaus und dann dort alleine
sterben
ich glaube da müssen wir alle das
gesamte gesundheitswesen dringend daran
arbeiten dass das nicht passiert ich
habe auch sehr emotionale sachen erlebt
gerade der letzten woche ein alter herr
kurt 19 erkrankt wo ganz klar war und
dass er keine chance hat wirklich das zu
überleben weil es auch nicht gewünscht
war er wollte auch nicht und dass er
bearbeitet wird und seine ehefrau war
auch im mit 19 erkannt und er lag auf
der intensivstation seine tochter war
bei und dann haben wir abends irgendwie
versucht und haben es auch hinbekommen
dass die ehefrau sigrid 19 positiv waren
mit entsprechenden persönliche
schutzausrüstung versehen dass die ihren
mann besuchen konnte und das sind zwar
sehr traurigen moment sehr bewegen
moment aber das ist das was dann
intensiv medizin und menschlichkeit
auszeit und das dürfen wir bei aller
technik bei alle dem was wir da auch an
möglichkeiten nie aus dem auge verlieren
der patient und seine anke die stehen im
zentrum da müssen wir das menschliche
immer wieder berücksichtigt und das
versuchen mit biegen und brechen
umzusetzen dass hier keiner alleine
verstirbt sondern begleitet wird und
auch getröstet
durch die anwesenheit seiner liebsten
dann wenn es denn so sein muss diese
welt verlassen kann
das wäre eigentlich ein schönes
schlusswort professor jahns wenn ich
nicht noch ganz interessante fragen hier
für sie hätte youtube sebastian sailer
ist unterwegs er schreibt nicht würde
interessieren wie sich aufgrund der
erfahrung der ersten welle die
behandlung verbessert hat und ob sich
dadurch die mortalität auf der
intensivstation geändert hat gibt es da
schon operationen zu ja wir haben ganz
klare hinweise über die monate das
tatsächlich sterblichkeit insgesamt
leicht rückläufig ist insgesamt ist aber
auch so dass das erkrankung steckt und
das erkrankungsalter sich verschoben hat
also über die sommermonate herbst
september/oktober die das mittlere
erkrankungsalter war geringer fast 20
jahre unter dem erkrankungsalter im märz
april und je älter die patienten sind
die auf der intensivstation kommen die
höher ist die sterblichkeit ist muss man
ganz klar sagen alter ist ein ganz
starker vorhersagewert für sterblichkeit
also deshalb haben wir ein absinken der
sterblichkeit beobachtet diese aber
immer noch verhältnismäßig hoch das
haben wir letzte tage sehen und wir
haben natürlich verbesserte
behandlungswege wir haben wenig an
medikamenten das muss man offen und
ehrlich sagen was übrig geblieben ist
ist zum beispiel das kortison das haben
sie vielleicht alle vernommen das geben
wir regelmäßig den patienten schwer
sauerstoff licht ist sind und beatmet
werden das scheint tatsächlich
sterblichkeit zu reduzieren wie große
studien bisher gezeigt haben was wir
nebenwirkungen verursacht und im
langzeitverlauf in der gesamt beobachten
das gilt abzuwarten die nächsten daten
in den kommenden monaten publiziert
werden aber insgesamt sind unsere
abläufe halt professioneller geworden
wir müssen vielmehr jetzt wie und wann
wir was machen und ich glaube diese
kenntnisse wenn sie 19% mal haben dann
erkennen sie relativ rasch wann der
punkt gekommen ist
wo man was machen muss zum beispiel eine
beratung einleiten muss oder wenn man
achten muss und welche anderen maßnahmen
zu ergreifen sind und ich glaube da
haben wir einiges gelernt und da ist es
tatsächlich besser geworden dann habe
ich hier noch doch einige kritische
stimmen ich habe so ein bisschen das
gefühl dass es unter unseren
zuschauerinnen immer noch menschen gibt
oder zuschauer gibt die der meinung sind
es kann alles gar nicht so schlimm sein
wenn zum beispiel im sommer intensiv
betten abgebaut wurden was ist der grund
dafür schreiben hier gleich mehrere
kommentare kommentatorinnen ich muss
ganz ehrlich sagen weiß nicht ganz genau
was die kommentators meilen also unseres
wissens nach und von der die liaison von
afag gesellschaft und habe ich ja schon
betonte sind nicht die polizei können
das selber nicht messen sind ein
intensivbetten nicht abgebaut worden
vielleicht bezieht man sich darauf den
anteil der freien und gemeldeten betten
und darauf habe ich ja eben schon
hingewiesen tatsächlich haben einige
kliniken zu viele freie betreiber
intensivbetten gemeldet dass den
eindruck erweckt hatte dass wir sehr
viele haben dadurch durch den ständiger
ermahnungen richtig zu melden sind
tatsächlich in der folge im oktober
tatsächlich 1500 bis 1600 intensivbetten
abgebaut worden
die waren aber auch die in dem sinne
auch gar nie frei gewesen also da muss
man wirklich die zahlen mit vorsicht
genießen so jetzt wollen als wären sie
kommen mal nach vorne schauen also die
diskussion um den harten fakten haben
wir ja schon wir können ja mal ganz kurz
hier einen aktuellen tweet von karl
lauterbach zeigen den hat er vor zwei
stunden abgesetzt habe ich gerade noch
mal gefunden
auf meinem rechner habe ich den gelegt
es ist natürlich was wir denken und was
noch nicht falsch ist eine antwort auf
den kollegen böhmermann macht den laden
dicht ihr deppen hat er vor 12 stunden
geschrieben und er hat gemeint er wird
es nicht so sagen aber es ist das was
wir denken nicht falsch ist lockt damit
zweieinhalb wochen für dann zwei wochen
von armin laschet vorgeschlagen wird
erneut nichts bringen die opferzahlen
werden viel zu hoch die bundeskanzlerin
hat heute ja auch schon dazu
aufgefordert doch wirklich was zu tun
es gibt eine frage per e mail an sie von
isabelle müller was raten sie uns als
arzt in dieser panisch angespannt
außer der gegenseitigen rücksichtnahme
die da immer kommt also quasi was ist
jetzt das was sie haben es gerade schon
mal angesprochen am anfang des gesprächs
verlangen oder sich wünschen würden
also ich würde mir wünschen dass wir
tatsächlich als gesellschaft tatsächlich
solidarisch ständen das bedeutet
tatsächlich dass wir uns nicht
gegenseitig vorhaltungen machen und
dauernd sagen das stimmt alles nicht
sondern eins muss man sagen
die botschaft ist es ist wirklich nicht
besonders schön ist es schlimm das ist
die erste böse zweite ist wir können das
wirklich schaffen ich bin der festen
überzeugung und wir müssen einfach
wirklich zusammen rücken auch die 16
ministerpräsidenten zusammen und endlich
mit einer stimme reden das ist mein
zweiter wunsch mein dritter wunsch wäre
dass wir das einfach befolgen was wir
seit monaten eigentlich immer so ein
bisschen predigen abstand halten muss
händehygiene
denn das alles laufen würde wenn das
alles klappen würde dann wäre ich schon
sehr sehr glücklich und wir müssen auch
in allen geschäften etc
wenn ich selber und ich bin selten
unterwegs in geschäften in den letzten
wochen das gesehen aber wie dazu
gegangen ist dann wurde hat mich gar
nichts mehr dass die infektionszahlen
weiter hohes wenn er das alles einfach
mal umsetzen würden dann wäre es
vielleicht weniger stimmen als es jetzt
ist jetzt befürchte ich tatsächlich wird
man zu drastischen maßnahmen greifen
müssen wenn wir nicht tatsächlich im
januar ein ganz ganz böses erwachen im
neuen jahr erleben wollen vielen dank
professor jahns dass sie heute abend so
viel zeit für uns hatten das zu
beantworten ich habe hier noch wirklich
viel mehr fragen aber wir müssen
irgendwann tatsächlich mal zum schluss
kommen ich glaube wir haben die
wichtigsten sachen dann doch hier
abhaken können in diesem sinne bedanke
ich mich bei ihnen für ihre zeit bedanke
mich bei euch und bei ihnen für die
kommentare und für die ganzen fragen die
wir hatten und wünscht dann erstmal
einen ruhigen abend einen ruhigen tag
noch und bis zum nächsten leisten wir
sind wieder da für euch wahrscheinlich
morgen das dann macht's gut
und tschüss